We learned this morning that an additional
6.6 million people have lost jobs and filed
for unemployment benefits.
Now the real numbers are actually much worse
than the official numbers.
And I'll explain why in a moment.
You might remember that two weeks ago we learned
that in the prior week, 3.3 million people
lost their jobs.
Last week, we learned that the week before,
six point eight million people filed for unemployment.
And today we learned that last week, 6.6 million
more people filed for unemployment benefits.
That now gets us to sixteen point seven million
people losing their jobs and filing for unemployment
benefits in just three weeks.
Now, to understand the magnitude of this,
the labor force was right around 158 million
before this started.
That means 10 percent of the labor force has
filed for unemployment benefits in the last
three weeks.
Now, the question is, can we trust that number?
Well, we can trust it.
But the real number is much higher.
Why?
Well, number one, there are tons of people
who lost a job but don't qualify for unemployment
benefits.
Not every type of job necessarily qualifies
for unemployment benefits.
There are people who are working under the
table, as the phrase may be.
There are people in certain jobs where you
don't qualify for unemployment benefits.
So the real number is higher.
And number two, the systems for filing have
been so overwhelmed that there are tons of
people who have been trying to file but couldn't.
Unemployment is administered, managed at the
state level like we have the department in
Massouda, Massachusetts, Department of Employment
that manages Massachusetts unemployment.
The Web sites are often not up to the task
of handling the increased traffic.
The phone systems are often collapsing.
So there are lots of people who have been
trying to file but haven't been able to.
So in early May, the April unemployment report
is going to be released and it could conceivably
hit 15 percent unemployment, which would be
historically high.
I mean, you have to go back to the Great Depression
era where you had, you know, 25 percent in
1933.
We've not seen numbers like that, 15, maybe
even we can get to 20 percent since these
are tragic numbers.
It's going to take a long time to recover
regardless of Trump saying it's going to go
up like a rocket and we're going to be reinstating
everything very quickly.
A lot of jobs are not going to be reinstated
as the economy starts to open back up.
Many restaurants and other businesses are
not coming back.
They are closed for good.
It's going to be a long process.
Many people will be starting essentially from
scratch, looking for new jobs.
Now, a few reminders.
Here is Donald Trump's press.
I'm sorry.
Commerce Secretary Wilbur Ross saying just
weeks ago that Corona virus will be good for
the economy while giving us a hacking cough
as he says it.
Take a look.
But I want to talk about a victory lap over
a very unfortunate, very malignant disease.
But the fact is that does give businesses
yet another thing to consider when they go
through their review of their supply chain.
And top of all the other things, because you
had czars.
You have the African swine virus there.
Now you have this.
That's another risk factor that people need
to take into account.
So I think it will help to accelerate the
return of jobs to North America, some to U.S.,
probably some to Mexico.
So we can add that to the montage of really
clueless people who have no idea what they're
talking about.
Now, in the meantime, and we're going to talk
about this in the interview segment today.
People still haven't gotten their twelve hundred
dollar stimulus checks from reports.
I'm seeing the unemployment supplement from
the federal government of up to six hundred
dollars a week still hasn't started in many,
if not almost all of the states that are through
which people are receiving unemployment benefits,
not to a significant degree.
Despite Trump's claims during his press conferences
that billions and billions of dollars in the
paycheck protection plan funds have been doled
out already.
It seems that very few businesses have actually
received any money so far.
We're months into this thing now.
And where are those benefits?
Where is the money?
These are very ugly.
Thursday are made worse by the fact that the
Trump administration has been so brutally
behind on all of this.
So we need a government that can actually
behave responsibly and react quickly.
We don't have it right now.